- This is so neat.
Nice to see you.
- Good to see you.
- Come on over.
Oh, my gosh,
I love this New York moment we're having.
- I can't wear heels anymore.
You know?
- I can't either.
Not unless I'm being paid a lot of money.
- Well.
- Yeah.
- It's just not happening.
- Yes. I'm with you.
I'm with you.
But this is so New York.
We're celebrating New York.
This is like working
girl central right here,
like the movie.
I love it.
(audience applauding)
- Whoops, I used to be
able to run in these.
- Oh gosh.
- Yeah, I mean,
she used to chase politicians,
you know through the capitol.
- You bet.
- That sounds like hell.
Oh my God.
Well Maury,
you're now the longest
running daytime host ever.
(audience applauding)
I mean.
- He's the goat.
- Exactly.
- He's the goat, Maury.
- Ever, I challenging.
- Kelly just hang around long enough.
- I'm like challenge accepted.
- And by the way,
I'm a little upset because
if you would have started
your show one year later,
you would not have won
the Emmy against me.
And I would have won the Emmy.
All you had to do was wait a year.
- That was so rude of me.
- So rude.
- It was so rude.
Do they have an award
for longest show running?
I mean,
that's, that's amazing.
- Yeah I know.
- It's a lot of work.
- It's called assisted living.
(laughing)
- Well, so wait.
You guys used to do a show together.
So what's it like
working with your spouse?
- Oh I hated it, absolutely.
He's, well he's a quick study you know?
And I'm like,
oh I got to read the research,
got to write down
questions and everything.
- Yeah.
- And he'd look at it and go,
"Okay I'm ready."
And I was like, really?
You know it's just.
- 'Cause I'm a lot older than you.
- No, no, you're not.
You're, he's an 82.
- Ah stop it.
- And I turned 75.
- That's not a lot older.
- Wait a minute,
so that's a century and
a half between us, right?
- No, no, no, no.
- She's like,
no I don't accept this.
So wait,
so what do you each
love about living here?
- First of all,
anything you want in life is in this city.
- I will say that.
Yeah, you can do anything
- And it's up all night.
- Yeah.
- This town is up all night.
No other town in the country.
Unless it's a fabricated
town like Las Vegas,
no other town is up all night.
- Yeah.
And even just right outside of town.
There's beautiful mountains.
There's beautiful.
It's just like,
you can kind of get everything
it's a train ride away.
It's it's a beautiful thing.
So what is your favorite part?
- You can order in Chinese food.
- I love you.
I just did that the other night.
- And they deliver.
- Just did that,
we were like working all day
and I was like,
and we're post mating 'cause I can't move.
I was like and I got Chinese,
it was so good.
They have such great food here.
- Absolutely.
- Yeah.
- That's another thing.
No bagel is like a New York bagel.
- I will tell you it's a very good bagel.
Toasted bagel with cream cheese.
Wait, so Maury,
you're about to start season 31.
- Yeah.
- That's incredible.
(audience applauding)
- Well, I mean,
you know about this longest
running talk show host.
I mean,
look, I didn't think much about it.
And then I realized longer
than Phil Donahue,
longer than Oprah,
longer than all this stuff.
- It's amazing yeah.
- So we started in '91.
So you add it up.
- Wow.
- 31.
- It's such a cool legacy.
- Really?
- Yeah,
dude.
I mean that's amazing,
31 years.
- You don't think you
can make it that long?
- No.
- Look, first of all,
we work for the same company, right?
- Yes.
- Okay, all right.
It's family.
- No, it is.
I just mean like,
that's I mean whew that's a long time.
- You don't think you can make that?
- You know what,
at this point in my life I'm non committal
in a lot of things.
- I've heard.
- So I'm just,
I don't like to throw anything out there.
So and so yeah.
- You can do it girl.
- I can do it.
Okay now I have the touch.